just one year after launch chat GPT has
well over 100 million daily active users
and next week open AI is opening the
floodgates allowing developers to profit
on their platform by selling custom GPT
agents all you have to do is convince 1%
of the user base to pay you $1 per month
for your custom agent and you'll be a
decamillionaire by the end of the year
by the end of today's video you'll know
how to get rich from this once in
a-lifetime shovelware Opportunity it is
January 5th 2024 and you were watching
the code report building a custom GPT
agent is way too easy literally all you
do is go down to my gpts create a new
agent give it some custom instructions
and conversation starters and maybe
upload some files with some custom data
release it on the store next week then
slap the hood and tell people how this
bad boy can solve all their problems the
barrier to entry is extremely low and
that means the GPT store will likely be
filled with crapware by the end of next
week but it may not be the only store in
town for long coincidentally screenshots
for Google's B Advanced were just leaked
hours ago it looks like Bard may have
its own pay tier based on Gemini Ultra
in the future along with a Marketplace
for developers but that's pure
speculation at this point now another
big question mark is what will the
revenue split be on the Chachi BT store
will it be 7030 like apple or will it be
much lower than that because open AI is
kind of doing most of the work here in
any case there'll be some kind of
leaderboard so if you actually create
something useful there's a good chance
you'll make a lot of money now the
question becomes what should I actually
build there's already a bunch of Agents
built by open AI like this one that will
create a diecut sticker for you and then
provide a link where you can actually
buy those stickers these are pretty cool
but luckily I have some Banger ideas
that I'm not going to build that you can
have for free all you have to do is
subscribe to the channel and continue
watching idea number one is an agent
that controls your smart home you give
it access to all your cameras so it can
do things like automatically turn on the
heated floors when you get out of the
shower idea number two is to build a
stock broker agent it provides
investment advice and can be used to
automatically gamble your users's money
when hooked up to apis like alpaca idea
number three is to create an AI personal
trainer that gets you in shape by
calling you a fat every day until you
get skinny okay those ideas sounded
pretty dumb now that I say them out loud
so unsubscribe I guess but but to be
brutally honest the best idea is to just
go out and find the trendiest AI SAS
products steal their ideas and put them
on the GPT store as your own but what
I'm building is an AI agent for my open
source spellfire library that can
remotely execute code currently Chachi
BT can only execute python but my fire
breather agent can execute JavaScript in
a sandboxed environment on my server
this magic is made possible thanks to
chat GPT actions formerly known as
plugins you'll notice down here at the
bottom on the configuration that we have
an action that points to my URL this
allows chaty to access an API that I
built that contains the secret sauce for
anything the end user would want to pay
for the next step is to build an actual
API there's a million different ways to
do that but one typescript option I've
been liking recently is Nitro it does
file system routing and can be easily
deployed almost anywhere so a chat GPT
action is basically just an HTTP API
that chat GPT understands the first step
is to add an ai- plugin Json file to the
well-known directory on your website or
URL it just provides basic information
about what the API actually does the
next step is to build an API that
actually does something useful that's
beyond the scope of this video but
basically you're going to have some
input data like the information provided
by the user in the chat you'll take that
information and do something useful on
your server and then send a response
that will go back to the user in the
chat now what's crucial is that GPT
understands this API and it does that
with the open API spec which is a
standard format either in yaml or Json
that provides a consistent structure for
documenting restful apis now you could
generate the schema by hand but
hopefully you chose a framework that can
build One automatically in Nitro this is
experimental which I can update here in
my config then I can either provide it
as a URL or paste it here into the
browser once that's done all you have to
do is deploy your API somewhere and then
you can start testing it here in the
browser congratulations you now have
your own artificial slave I mean agent
that you can start exploiting for a
profit next week this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one